p comme tous les citoyens jeu je regarde
alors on regarde quand on regarde les
sondages ce qu'on entend ce qu'on nous
dit et c'est donc vous avez vu comme moi
ou vous voyez comme moi que pour ceux
qui regardent que benoît hamon va avoir
de grosses difficultés à être au
deuxième tour ça ça me gêne pas moi je
vais voter je peux voter benoit hamon
même s'il n'est pas au deuxième tour
heureusement d'ailleurs parce qu'on
n'est jamais sûr de rien j'avais voté
jospin il a prêté au deuxième tour donc
et s'il y avait eu plus de jeunes qui
avaient voté jospin on aurait évité
quand même ce qui s'est passé ça c'est
un autre sujet mais benoît hamon quand
on regarde moi je me dis très bien si
demain il ya un danger
moi je dis comme je le pense si demain
moi je regarderai le la veille l'avant
veille de l'élection du premier tour je
regarderai sondages en tendresse que
disent les gens s'il ya un danger de
revivre le 21 avril c'est à dire d'avoir
en face à face au 2e tour
fillon fillon contre marine le pen c'est
à dire quelqu'un qui est mis en examen
contre quelqu'un qui est mis en examen
par delà les idées que porte marine le
pen que je combats de toutes mes forces
eh bien je ne voterai pas pour benoît
hamon à ce moment là parce que je
voterai pour celui pour celui pas
forcément quelqu'un qui est en marche
peut-être pour un insoumis si c'était
lui qui était en situation je voterai
pour celui qui évitera d'avoir le duel
entre les deux mises en examen entre la
droite extrême et l'extrême droite
pourquoi la droite extrême parce que on
n'a pas besoin de la purge libérale que
nous propose un fillon d'ailleurs il l'a
mais de moins en moins vu l'état de ses
finances
et on peut pas faire confiance je veux
dire une plaisanterie on peut pas faire
confiance pour gérer la france à
quelqu'un qui avec 24000 euros de
recettes par mois n'arrive pas à mettre
des sous de côté
voilà